this is like the most slippery slope
question because it's my favorite topic
slip let's get into it what the [ __ ] is
going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends yup
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
honestly when i say it like that i sound
so fake when i did you just hear the
intro i'll be honest that was so
much welcome back to the unwax podcast
blah blah blah
show some heart sofia
run it back to the unwax podcast
i cry when i do it instead hi guys
welcome back i know that was just way
too much um with your favorite sisters
sophia and
sistine yee
how baby we just got back from
stagecoach and let me tell you there are
still dirt in my eyes oh yeah i remember
going home blowing my nose and just
black
stuff came out cute it was really nice
super hot it was great and now i don't
even want to know what's filled in my
lungs
yeah no it was a stacked weekend my
liver is quaking yeah not feeling great
i'm sort of feeling the come down you
know we don't have covid but every time
you go on a bender or a festival for a
few days in a row you just kind of feel
the repercussions of it i feel a little
bit under the weather totally well it's
because when you go to these events
you're there for
literally like 10 hours and you're
non-stop walking you're barely eating
the easiest thing to grab is a drink and
plus when you're living in a house of
people
you know
it would be wrong to not have a
margarita at 11am with your breakfast i
don't think i've ever drank so many
frozen marks just throughout the day for
fun yeah in my life but it was so great
i actually loved it i don't remember
last time i just kind of enjoyed having
alcohol whenever it's true because you
know how i always say that i just
feel like i'm not as fun anymore when it
comes to drinking
it's nice to sort of let that guard down
and just enjoy no i feel that but i had
a lot of fun i
i would say though
in comparison to other ones we've been
to they were probably the least amount i
knew about for the last two days the
lineup the lineup yeah i feel like the
friday i knew everybody i knew the
headliners for all three days but it
wasn't all of my favorite favorites
that's what's interesting at some point
when you go to a concert or festival and
you actually don't know any of the
lyrics and you're just sort of standing
there
it's not that fun it's not it's not like
i i would say though and we both agreed
on this our favorite was carrie
underwood
wow can we talk about the legs on that
woman we just talk about the entire body
face voice of that woman she was
unbelievable and i actually have never
seen her live or even considered ever i
she was a i wouldn't say she's my
favorite country artist now she is but
she's a great performer and i would
literally put prosthetics into my calves
to have them look like hers
she how old is she 39 40 yeah she has
two kids
ridiculous everything i know her body
looks insane and her voice
was so good they brought um out the guy
from oxford yeah
actually rose let me tell you he was up
there and he was living his best life
they both actually complimented each
other very well vocally it was it was
epic yeah she was by far the best
definitely have a girl crush on her now
yeah it was really fun the only part i
did not like about
going to palm springs was driving alone
i don't think i've ever made that trip
up by myself yeah why did you drive
for some reason this girl wanted to
drive alone and go earlier than
everybody else can i tell you the three
hours by herself i'll tell you my
thought process i go
sometimes you know we talk a lot sophie
and i are always communicating we're
always on face time with our family
always talking talking on this podcast i
thought you know it might be nice to sit
in the car
and just talk to myself
and it made me more depressed yeah i
mean when you're but when you're driving
because at least when you're not driving
you're a passenger you can go on your
phone you kind of like play with the
music
you're dude
i
you're
listen to any music the whole time
that's kind of weird that's that's
that's just your problem i know i mean
what do you do in a long car ride like
that you have to have someone with you i
was just making checklists in my head i
was making pros and cons in my head
making hairs in my head that sounds
terrible i was with my boyfriend driving
over and we just listened to uh
crime junkie
all of the crime podcasts why do you
think that was so much fun
bond over crime anything crime
documentaries crime podcasts you don't
ever watch it alone but when you're in a
relationship it's almost like a sweet
thing people do with each other i know
it's like a weirdly romantic yeah type
of thing to bond over well it's
especially in a long car ride you're
just trying to figure out who the
murderer is and he thinks it's funny
because i can't help but make comments
on every single part of this the problem
there was a one where someone was
killing a guy and like they were trying
to figure out the clues and i'm just
there saying how did you not know sophia
let me tell you if you're ever in her
presence listening or watching a movie
or doing something of that matter
she is the most annoying commentator
ever she talks the whole time yeah we'll
be just past the credits of a film and
she'll say what's going on yeah i'm like
i'm at the same point as you i don't
know like what's the story about why are
there all these names yes guy i'm like
we just met him i don't know do you have
kids no i know i do because i just i'm
so curious i just want to know what's
going on one of those people i can't not
i i'm big you and stuff doesn't work for
me relationship wise friendship-wise
understanding wanting to know the plot
but
i are on the same
point where we both don't know what it
is i can't give you answers i know i i
have to i know i know i'm just expecting
you to all of a sudden have more clarity
than i do on all the situations i have
to say though after this crazy weekend
nothing made me happier than parking my
butt on my cloud couch
having pimple cream on my face humble
brag
yeah humble brag i spent all my money on
a cloud couch anyway
sitting there pimple cream on my face in
a bathrobe watching the met gala
everyone looking their best their best
glam and i felt like an actual slob
kebab wait i was relaxed you said that
everyone at the met looked their best to
what they in turn i'm gonna tell you if
you ever if any of you guys went to the
met you all did not look good i'm sorry
like that was just not a good outfit you
thought they were good i would say haley
bieber looked great well she always
looks good you know what i don't think
kelly needs minimal
anything kendall always looks good but
you're talking about models here
people that aren't models sometimes it's
harder to pose to get the glam right
sometimes what if you're interested
i'm not talking about randoms that are
showing up i'm talking about people that
have had professionals and designers
design their dress for and i just have
to say there was a theme it's like
gilded glam glamour gold whatever it is
and it could have been such a great met
theme everyone stuck to it i was hoping
people would come out in more
bridgerton-esque that's what i was me
too like someone dressed as mary
antoinette like that would have been so
cool virgin people could have just worn
their costumes to the event and they
didn't even wear it and they wore
something that was just so much more
modern so now we're basically the
fashion police of this podcast who do
you think was the best dressed um
i'm not gonna lie
random but i thought i wouldn't say
she's best dressed but i thought
julianne moore looked very appropriate
very classy she dressed for her age i
liked her hair
sure okay i liked kendall's outfit i
didn't like the bleached eyebrows
um i hated kylie's i'm sorry no shade to
kylie but the backwards that wasn't like
everyone had everyone here
you know oh you know i loved emma
chamberlain's outfit
i loved her outfit i thought it was so
cute to crown everything i think she
really killed it she also has like a
really good body yeah she could
literally put anything on her and she'd
make it look good i thought i noticed
this wasn't on theme at all but like i
thought lori harvey's dress was like
really sexy and cool but i don't think
she dressed yet for the event i thought
it was interesting there's been a lot of
debate because kim kardashian wore the
marilyn monroe dress oh that's what
chloe's looked pretty identical to and
everyone's saying that chloe looked a
lot better than okay really
did you see that they uh came out with
how she put on the dress uh yeah i think
didn't they rip it a little bit and like
to no they they couldn't even zip the
butt part no i know i think they adapt
they kept that open they stitched it or
something i didn't really watch the
whole thing but i mean that is insane
and shows how much power she has that
she was able to actually take the actual
merlin monroe dress my favorite part
though about watching the entire met was
seeing all of the
ex-couples show up sometimes with
different people sometimes not and for
me i was playing like a puzzle game in
my head saying okay austin butler just
walked in and he used to date vanessa
hudgens they're here together jacob
lordy's here and he's single but kai is
there with austin butler and like and
then shawn mendes is there shawn mendes
camilla bear and i was like phoebe
bridgers and pete davidson oh i didn't
even think of that yeah
i was thinking
there's no better place on the planet to
run into your ex than at the met you
have glam you have a gown on and if you
feel your best like
no i know i know that's me i know
exactly that is the time to show up and
show to your ex that you are doing
better off with them awesome butler
looked great just had to note that
that's my top pick of the night he was
pretty great is that man drinking we
don't know fountain of youth maybe we
said we didn't like blondes
he's he's an ex he's exception
i just think right the hudgens did look
really she looked great as well do i
think they'd look good together
yeah
yeah they would look really cool
together i do i know i really do i do i
do agree with that but yeah i don't know
it didn't surprise me i was really
expecting more
um but i actually just to change topics
this has been i don't know if you knew
where i was yesterday i sat by myself i
never do this but i went to a random
coffee shop just i feel like you do this
a lot
well i say oh actually that's so true
you do it a lot that's so true
everyone i encourage you to just go to a
random coffee shop and work by yourself
i never do that really like for work
i'll go get a book or drink coffee or
wine whatever but it was so much fun
just people watching and sitting outside
i i got so much things i promise you i
will never be one of those girls sitting
at a cafe for multiple hours using free
wi-fi working on my computer
why would you want to
like a starbucks and you see those
people just sitting there don't walk the
starbucks is that's the place you avoid
you know that's like obviously serious
so you want like an aesthetic coffee
shop yes
okay you need like a pretty yeah any
like a pretty one that maybe makes like
a drink that looks a little purple and
fun
oh yeah you gotta like feed yourself too
a little bit more instagram yeah
instagramable cafe but it was fun
actually getting out and like watching
everybody on their computer doing some
sort of work i think it's important to
sort of break your routine and do
something that you wouldn't normally do
um something just happened above us and
i think it's haunted oh yeah
okay so we have a really exciting guest
on today that sistine was really awesome
and found she is so cool
yes her name is shan she's sort of a
relationship
intimacy expert sophie and i love this
topic so much and i also think you guys
like to hear it because most of your
listener questions are about
relationships intimacy even being
confident without someone and i'm just
stoked to talk to her i've listened to
her a lot of her episodes a lot of her
guests are really cool so we're gonna
have a real
vulnerable honest conversation and i
cannot wait so stay tuned for shan
[Music]
alright guys today we have an author
intimacy educator and sexologist who
describes herself as dr ruth meets
rihanna that's pretty epic using her
podcast lovers and friends and her
multiple social media platforms she
teaches people how to be more confident
in and out of relationships while giving
sex advice dating love and everything in
between this is shan boudreau
oh my god that was reading [ __ ] that
was great i'm not gonna lie i didn't
breathe that whole time we get nervous
doing these intros for people they're
very nerve-wracking
no but i'll tell you sophie and i only
get nervous in showing someone that
we're really excited about yeah we're
really excited so if you don't care
you're like if i say something wrong
you'll get over it i know oh my gosh
well thank you for coming in thank you
for having me you know
a lot of people
it's hard to get people to come on the
show and you followed up with me and you
were so sweet and so kind and you're on
it and i was like wow like a lot of
people don't
try and just try to make an effort so we
really appreciate you taking the time
listen i have a podcast too
i know how hard or people say yes but
that yes means like secretly in brackets
2027 yes but they don't like say that
yeah and you're like following up with
them it can be a lot so i get it when
you're just like no i'm trying to have
an interesting conversation i love the
conversation you guys have here so i'm
grateful to be a part of it well
actually i like i have to say the way i
actually found you
was on
you were all too hot to handle yes yeah
and you know what's good when people say
like the way that i found you do you
hold your breath because you're like
what are they gonna do what are you
doing
where was i
where did i go i don't even know so i
saw you on red tube and um
yeah you were giving a seminar to the
ladies about talking to their cookie
yoni yes
you can call it whatever you want that's
the joy yeah
we call it anything um but i really
thought that was so epic and i tried to
do it myself and i just felt super
uncomfortable but i really liked it yeah
i really liked what you had to say about
it i mean you said that there was some
power and and talking to it and sort of
you know making it your best friend but
do you think that really helps when you
talk to your yoni i mean you can create
the relationship however you want to
which is the amazing thing about
relationships is identifying like what
brings you joy what gives you strength
and so
i think for a lot of people who have
vulvas and a lot of people identify as
women in general you're sort of like i
have a one and a half year old daughter
and every time her diaper comes off she
grabs her vulva right and
she knows eyes nose ears mouth vulva
because i'm like you identify it but
there are some of us who grew up like
don't touch that right don't look at
that that's a bad part so you are
encouraged not to have this relationship
you're encouraged to disassociate and to
associate it with shame so for someone
like that it can be helpful as you get
older to be like what's up right like i
don't think i've ever really like
formally introduced myself because i've
been told to ignore you like i did a
youtube video once about women in
different ways that women orgasm and
someone was saying that like them them
and their sister were playing with like
hoses when they were like six or seven
and she goes to her sister like take the
hose and put it on your hoo-ha or cookie
or whatever they said it feels amazing
and they weren't saying it like in a
sexual way it was just like it's a fact
of life yeah they feel like this feels
great yeah that feels great and then the
older sister you know who had probably
gone through a bit more socialization
was like don't ever say that don't ever
talk about that do not do that that is
bad that's a bad body part so for that
individual getting to a place where it's
like this is a good body part right i'm
sorry for ignoring you i'm sorry for
labeling you as bad or letting other
people's assumptions about you dictate
how we connect talking can be helpful
definitely
now you've become like this person that
is breaking the norm and the stereotype
and the the shame behind knowing your
body and understanding like something
that we all kind of go through which is
like this is something a part of
ourselves that we haven't even explored
what made you even want to start
becoming the voice for people that don't
really have a voice or even know what
questions to ask i think there's always
like two kinds of people who come into
any purpose in life right like there's
the people who it's like it was so good
for me so i want other people to learn
because i know a lot i've experienced
the right way and i want whatever quote
unquote right is and i want to guide
others and then there's people who are
like yo it [ __ ] sucked for me right
and i made so many mistakes i put myself
in so many negative situations so in
essence i'm that person like i started
learning about sex because i had a super
shitty teen sex life i had every
negative experience you can have under
the books zero orgasms no connection a
lack of understanding of my body i
thought my clitoris was something that
was like inside which is why in porn you
know women scream so much so i'm like
when i find the right penis that's
currently the right way
it'll find that button like those and i
was like having sex thinking that so
i'm like if i didn't know so much and i
was so misinformed there has to be other
people so i educated myself first out of
need and then i was like wow someone
else should be offering this information
and i was like mitch why can't someone
else be you right exactly yeah see this
the following you have from it it's like
a lot of people most people are curious
about it and i feel like it's just hard
to know where to even start and you you
guys you just go back to even the basics
i actually saw a video the other day on
your i was stalking you on your
instagram and you even went on in your
time i just had a kiss like just even
stuff like that where people like no one
thought like told me about it or even
anything like that that's true sophie
and i did look up a youtube video how to
make out because we genuinely that's the
problem we go to school sex ed didn't
really exist for us we were afraid to
even talk about our body parts as kids
and what felt good and what anything was
and
i mean are you guys great maker routers
i think can i actually say yes i know i
am i pride myself on it you know
because we were so uneducated in just
the basics of everything i didn't
believe that i was good at anything
until i was told i was good at it yeah
that's actually true so
do you have a lot of people coming to
you for advice i don't know how to do
this i'm embarrassed that i can't do
that
it's getting better i mean i've been in
the space now for 18 years
wow so when i first started i don't
think that the search engines or
information wasn't as vast so my job was
actually a lot easier back in the day
because people would be like i don't
know how to orgasm i was like let me
introduce you to the clitoris like i've
never heard that word before or like oh
i want to try anal but it hurts and i'm
like oh you've got two sphincters and so
now so much of that is googleable or you
wouldn't see a video so the questions i
get are not usually as simple as like
how do i do this one thing i want to
kiss better you know what's the how to
because you would have just looked it up
on youtube or google did a question
you're gonna ask me is like when i was
five
paragraphs right right so like all the
more nuances that come with it which you
know makes my job more interesting but
um definitely more difficult and also
never ending sometimes people say to me
like oh like how can you talk about that
every day for so long i'm like there's a
billion different versions that each
person has in this planet there's always
things to explore and understand i'm
still learning every day no there's so
many things to learn and i think that
the hardest part about all of this is
really finding a source or a person not
my foot on the couch i think i keep like
trying to like find no go do it fine by
the way any way you want this is one wax
but you can go any way you guys okay so
my thing is like i remember growing up
not knowing really anything about my
body my my parents really talked about
with me it was like that's their
generation i had younger sisters and i
think the hardest part is really
researching and finding because when you
go on these sites it's pretty
intimidating i mean you're just looking
at scientific sources and they're mostly
written by men and so you don't really
know what you're reading is gonna be
accurate so if i was someone now like
trying to figure out or ask these
questions where do i go like who do i
talk to where do i start that if i can
didn't know that you existed yet you
know like now if i was you like for me
today and i didn't know i'd probably go
to your page and like really research
that's the great thing is i think that
there's actually so many different
options now so i might represent
information for some people but other
people may have more specific needs or
questions that i'm not answering so i
love the fact that i started in this
space a while ago where if i said i talk
about sex for a living people were like
what as if i said oh i talk about disco
ball i mean the jukebox is for a living
and you're like you made a job out of
that that's so obscure right now so many
more people have broken into the field
it's become a lot more widespread we
were watching uh the show recently bel
air and there was a house of influencers
and one of the influencers was like a
sex and relationship expert my husband
was like that is so based on you
but i was like that's just to me like
how much the field has broken open now
right so that to be said is probably
still difficult sure but i think it's a
lot easier now to identify like here's
who i can learn from if my parents
didn't yeah i would thought that you're
i wouldn't i guess because you're you
grew up with a lot of exposure i'm
assuming yeah i would have thought your
parents would have taught or told you a
lot really early on our parents were
more so um and i mean we don't talk to
anything about our dad and wise but with
our mom she was always one of those
people that never judged if we had any
questions she would answer them but
she's also like a little petunia she's
very excited and like delicate and she
doesn't want to talk about anything like
too much or too vulgar with us
especially when we were younger so i
think sophie and i really had to come
together and work on it with each other
like okay you kiss someone for the first
time sophia tell me everything i need to
know yeah but it's funny because now
today if we want to talk to our mom
about anything she's so open about it
and she loves it but that was because we
kind of reinforced it we created the
culture we created the culture in our
family and so now we are just like open
books do you think that it's the parents
responsibility to
inform their kids at an earlier age
about these things or do you think that
you know it's sort of
percent each the child and the parents
are supposed to it's definitely the
parents but i mean it's generational
yeah you know like i empathize with my
mom my mom
had this kind of same approach my mom
was very much like don't ask don't tell
me my parents applied the um ask me
anything you know way yeah it's it is
great but it's also a lot of pressure on
the kids
to initiate the conversations and to
know what to ask yeah yeah and to not
know what the i what's the boundaries
also exactly yeah i always make this
joke um that like my mom was like yeah
you're gonna ask me anything but my mom
positioned herself as somebody who was
like i was 18 with the love of my life i
had my first sexual experience
yeah and then i met your father
everything is great and then i'm like oh
man like i [ __ ] a carrot last night
14. like how do i tell this person right
it's like my mom she goes your dad was
my second boyfriend aside from my high
school boyfriend this is me and are like
oh my god are we doing this wrong right
i'm like i'm a black boy
yeah i think that there is such
almost shame behind sexuality and dating
and numbers and numbers is something
that i'd really like to get into because
a lot of men
i mean maybe women too but my experience
with men is they make you feel bad about
what your number is if it's too high
you're [ __ ] if it's too low you're
prudent won't put out so
i mean can we just like get into that
have you ever experienced that what's
your advice when you know you're asked
what your number is because i've been
asked that question and i've been told
just
lie and make up a number or say what you
think that they want to hear i mean i
don't know
it's interesting that there was a time
in my life where i literally woke up
every single day and thought about my
quote unquote body count yeah i
memorized my number and it would be i
was dating so it's at the forefront of
like if they ask what do i say if you
ask me today genuinely i have a ballpark
but like you just kind of forget because
like what's really the point if you ask
me when people have kissed i'm like hey
you know something yeah right right
right yeah
yeah it's kind of like if i thought
about it i'm sure can come up the number
and i know so many men um who in
particular don't know their number
either kind of the same reason because
they're not obsessed with like thinking
about it so i think to catch 22 is there
some value because yeah knowing
someone's ballpark could tell you a lot
about their sexual ethics right but also
there's probably more to the story so
for example for me i had seven sexual
partners by the time i was like 19 maybe
18. right and that was the bulk of my
sexual activity with this i was
searching for that magic penis like find
the clitoris right so
that if i told you my number i'm like
yeah the bulk of it though happened
within the first year and a half of me
becoming sexual so that isn't
necessarily reflective of the way that i
have sex or who have sex with today so i
get it from like that standpoint that if
your number is 200 that communicates to
me that like oh you have multiple sexual
partners you're very sexual liberal
right now i have additional questions
like
what's your sexual health status how
often do you get checked furthermore do
you think there's an overlap between my
friend's circle and your friend's circle
right that could make things awkward
right which that's actually the heart of
the question to me is like hey how is
this going to like impact my health and
also like my social health yeah right
but it's just a little stupid it was
actually had this funny conversation
with somebody who was like you know i
could definitely tell when a woman's had
multiple sexual partners what how can
you it's just looser
and i was like oh so you got a small
dick yeah
and then he was like what this is the
craziest myth i've ever heard i don't
know how that's unbelievable well it's
crazy to say to a pregnant woman who's
already had a kid because like what are
you insinuating about my time exactly
right so
he was like yeah you can tell because
it's looser i was like oh you have a
small dick he's like what do you mean i
was like well that means if someone's
had multiple partners most of their
partners are bigger than you so when you
go in you're like
that's true
okay now you don't like it when it
impacts your character something about
you exactly it has more to do are there
differences in people's size i'm sure
there are it has to do with one
compatibility of penis size and vaginal
size and has more to do with the
strength of your pelvic floor muscles
than probably a number of partners and
it's called kegels right that you do
that yes tighter yes i know i've heard
that you're supposed to do that every
stop wait that's what someone told me
yes
i've heard like when you're uh you know
when you're doing the turn signal it's
like
oh my god
do i do it no but no i know i
i think that um
most
people that feel insecure with their
body especially during sex sometimes it
comes from comments like that where you
know others project their insecurity on
you and then you feel almost ashamed
because i can't tell you how many
conversations i've had with guy friends
and girlfriends that they're embarrassed
about this the way this looks so they're
embarrassed about their performance or
they come too quickly or whatever it may
be only because someone else has made
them feel really bad about it do you
have any advice for people that just
you know
one
need help accepting who they are and
being confident in who they are in their
bodies
yeah i mean certain things obviously
take more explanation you know if you
we all have these ideas of what's good
and what's bad you know what's clean and
what's dirty when it comes to sex you
have to be aware of that you know when i
talk to people who have stis like herpes
right where in that like you know it's
difficult for them to find partners who
are accepting but you have to also
acknowledge that we're in a culture that
doesn't promote these conversations and
isn't very aware about what that is so
should i judge every person that i meet
who doesn't get it right or do i
empathize and be like it sucks that work
in this culture that like promotes these
ideals that are really harmful and not
actually based in fact so right there's
a mix of both of like
if you come very quickly for example um
there there's a book that i love that's
called she comes first and it was
written by dr ian kerner and essentially
he was a premature ejaculator right he
felt all this shame and guilt around him
that did the research and was like wait
a second penetration isn't even the
primary way that majority uh people with
volvo's get off so why am i making this
the focal point of my sexual performance
right he had a conversation with his
wife and his wife was like yeah i don't
really come from penetration anyways and
he's like cool let me get better at
other things that are more within my
body's capacity and capabilities right
right so it can be like it's good to
acknowledge you know where your
shortcomings i say shortcomings to
greater soul like in the realm of what
society thinks is good and bad yeah and
then also to like find workarounds and
then
choose people who can be a part of
solution-based dialogues so do you think
that it also takes because sometimes i
feel like when you've had sexual
partners and maybe you feel insecure
that you're almost like kind of for
females like lost your feminine energy
and you feel like that like divine sense
of self like that cause that's a good
question you know what i'm saying yeah
does it take a partner to also encourage
it and bring that to you because what if
you just stop feeling sexy or sexual and
you're like wow i just lost all my mojo
i mean like anything else in the world
if you're like
oh man my elbow hurts bad example but
you just troubleshoot right so you kind
of figure out am i sitting in a weird
way that's causing it to do that am i
hanging out with somebody who's putting
me in position for my elbow to be sore
am i actively doing things do i need to
get a brace so it's all just
troubleshooting so like for that
particular case you can be like what's
changed right so are there
circumstantial changes i can make are
there people because i think it's also
important too we live in a self-help
culture right now right of like yeah
it's you like love yourself choose
yourself i think you're sexy verbs which
is important it's a piece of puzzle
because like yeah it's okay alone yeah
and then there's a thing called
reciprocal determinism which means like
i might be one way towards you guys
because you're being nice to me right
like if i came in here sistine you were
like being closed off in a [ __ ] my
energy towards you would be different so
it's like i'm showing up for you in
reciprocity to how you're showing up
with me so sometimes it's that sometimes
it's not that you need to do the work
you need to be nicer you need to love
yourself it's more like no i'm hanging
around people who are not really
supporting me in this way so i got to
either let them know and ask them for
what i need or to find other people in
places how do you find the confidence to
ask your guy or girl whoever you're
dating what you need and because i think
sometimes like if you bring up us maybe
if it's involving sex or if maybe it's
involving something personal with
yourself it's a little bit of an
uncomfortable situation they could take
it personally you don't really know how
to approach it how do you
word it or how do you just say to your
partner like we need to have this talk
because this is what i need to fix or
this is something that would make me
feel better in bed or this is gonna like
how do you do it without
hurting the other person or making them
feel like it's a it's a them problem
when it's do you know how i'm trying to
word it yes i mean there's no perfect
answer yeah i like in a major argument
with somebody because i told my truth to
them and they got really offended by how
i told my truth so i'm not the expert on
like here's the perfect way right people
news it's uncomfortable it's a
troubleshooting process but ultimately
on the other side of that dialogue it's
better for you right like i said this is
a person that i'm in a you know a tiff
with right now where and they're like i
feel so hurt i feel so this and i was
like totally but i've been feeling this
way for like months right so you feel it
now today because i brought it to your
attention yeah so it's like yeah like is
the person that i tell like hey i'm not
orgasming or i don't feel sexy around
you or i feel like my sexual potential
is limited by some of the judgments that
you make or comments or the way that you
expect them to show up in the bedroom
that's uncomfortable for that person the
moment but like i've been having bad sex
with you for [ __ ] four years
so that's
at that point when it's just not
clicking for you and maybe it's clicking
for them but probably not the last one
or two times
is there anything you can really do to
salvage it or sort of reverse the
effects or is it sort of just we're not
compatible oh 100 you could salvage it
if somebody was willing to learn in a
job yeah they have a learner's mindset
yeah have you ever like had someone tell
you you're doing something wrong that
you're like i didn't even realize that
wasn't on my radar yeah so sometimes for
people that's not even on their radar i
mean myself and my husband like have
literal like textbook classic
uncomfortable conversations and we've
had them publicly and i think it's
helpful for people to see that model
like i literally have to ask him like
do you know what a compliment is
can you apply it to me
and he's like but i think these things
all the time or oh i show them in these
ways i'm like no i need to hear it you
know it's like love language yes and we
talked about that like in terms of
foreplay like his perception of foreplay
is like 20 minutes before sometimes but
i'm like i need the little touches all
day long right
like when i walk by you're like that ass
though and then i'm like oh and then 10
hours later because otherwise when you
try to initiate with me and it's been
very like sort of stoic and you know
transactional all day and then you try
initiate me at night i don't i don't
have the energy because i'm not really
energizing that sexual right right i
think first of all foreplay is totally
overlooked
and also i think that a lot of people
i'm just gonna say men because that
applies to what i'm used to
um they often mimic what their previous
partner or partners liked for foreplay
maybe they the girls didn't like
foreplay maybe they didn't need it and
so they just think that you you know
need the same right and so having that
conversation and saying no actually i
need this i mean it only gets better and
if it gets worse then that's a whole
difference that's actually the more
helpful piece of information yeah not
that like this person doesn't magically
know what i want because in a healthy
relationship hopefully there are some
places that you're like we flow right or
else you wouldn't have gotten together
right like i didn't have to explain to
them what my hobbies are they just got
it i'd have to explain to them like my
value system around god because they
just got it we align there i was gonna
ask you this question because like
congratulations you're also in your
second game
second baby
um and you said you were with your
partner for four years so far right
2015 so like somewhere in this
so were you guys together before you
started doing this and then did was he
always just initially really attracted
to like the whole like because some guys
get intimidated about females that talk
about sex publicly and then also talk
about their sex that they have and make
that an example um how did that even sit
like how did you know that he was going
to be kind of like the quote one for you
the interesting thing about my
relationship is that it didn't build in
that like you just know way you know
right you just know when you meet that
person yeah when you know you know it
was more like oh i really want to [ __ ]
this guy like that's the precipice of
how we got together but that to be said
at the present at the time that i met
him i was looking for a [ __ ] buddy i'm
not from america i was like on the fritz
of being deported so i couldn't legally
work and i just came out of a toxic
relationship so i was not ready to enter
into like anything substantial but i did
know that at the time i just finished
school for sexology i learned all this
amazing stuff and i wanted to invite
pleasure in my life okay so i was like
specifically looking for a friends who
benefits and the reason why i was like
oh this is the person i want to engage
in this with is that like
a lot of
men in particular if i'd say like oh i
study or talk about sex for a living
they're like what's your education where
did you go to school you know how long
have you been doing it so it becomes
like a jockeying thing of right oh like
they're trying to qualifications if i
can have sex with their girlfriend
better than them right right there's
this is like there's a need to and also
too like okay there's a lack of interest
and curiosity whereas in my husband
jared he was like i was so intrigued by
you and he's like i'm going to be very
honest i wanted to have sex with you so
i could be better for other people so he
came into it like you studied sex for a
living amazing let me teach this girl
so he was always fascinated like that's
at the root of i didn't talk publicly at
the time i did but like
not obviously at the platformer level
i'm not now yeah and that's how he knew
me he initially had dm me at some point
to say i like your work but it was like
for you know 10 people but totally he
was very much like interested so i
always say when people ask that question
of like i'm sure you get asked that too
like yeah how do you find somebody who's
not intimidated like one that person
finds you and two you kind of know
because you probably have so much
experience right meeting men who feel
minimized by you or are intimidated by
your family and so that comes up pretty
early and your radar is probably really
high for that you said you were a toxic
relationship previously so what were the
things that you saw in the last toxic
relationship that were completely
different from the one you were in now
and you were like okay this is polar
opposite this is going to be a healthier
relationship than what i had before
base rate for me like my husband thinks
i'm a good person and always evaluates
me as a good person first where i think
in my last relationship he was
constantly trying to look for like
problems you're bad or you're bad
because of this and a lot of it came
from his own bad behaviors and then
trying to justify why he did
manipulative things or cheated or
right he was like trying to
point the blame rather than being like i
have some work to do so at a base rate
when i knew that jared was my life
partner i was like i don't ever feel
like i have to qualify myself for you
right i have to audition for you to like
see the good in me right yeah and that
was a big difference and also jared has
like a learner's mindset
that's really important because being
with someone that's willing to learn and
adjust and also able to teach you things
i think is some of the most important
qualities in a relationship but going
back to what you were just saying why do
you think that
we
often try really hard to make the toxic
person in the relationship like us more
when deep down like women have a very
good intuition yeah we know in our gut
that something isn't right but we still
try to make it work so why do you think
sometimes we stay in it when we know
it's not right for us this is like the
most slippery slope question because
it's my favorite topic i could monitor
slip let's go well only just because
like i think um like what's something
that you guys have learned
scientifically that you know inside out
nutrition or fitness or is it yeah we
could say fitness yeah fitness outside
yeah and so when you learn about
different body types and so if i come to
you and i'm like i've been on the
treadmill for three years and i can't
and you're like oh here's why yeah right
so it's like when you don't understand
the biological basis for things then you
can find yourself spinning in
place or like in the dirt trying to
figure [ __ ] out where it's like no like
your body's actually set up as an
evolutionary flaw in many cases for that
so yeah love is the same thing where
like we're born to bond it is love is a
function of evolution so you're driven
to love so it's people think of love as
a feeling but feelings change and go i'm
having a good time right now if you guys
poured water in my face i'd be mad right
so but love is present regardless so
it's actually more of a neurological
condition um and so any condition
obviously if the circumstances aren't
ideal cannot be favorable for you
it's an addiction so
the [ __ ] up thing that actually
happens too in like a toxic relationship
is that your attachment system when you
feel like you're in danger you want to
move towards people that your brain has
identified as like loving individuals
which can actually be the person who
hurts you right so it's this weird push
and pull of like my for whatever reason
my brain decided you're my individual i
made a pair bond with you right we now
are you're
an addiction for me yeah but later on i
start to feel like harm from you in
danger from right and in those moments
of danger initially i might go into
fight or flight where i move away from
you but then my brain wants to be around
the people that are within my attachment
system so i'm drawn back to you right so
like your own brain creates this system
that makes it very difficult for you to
get out of toxic relationships because
your brain doesn't care if you're happy
your brain just works off of like again
an outdated survival mode so that to be
said i encourage everybody it was the
most freeing thing for me coming out of
my toxic relationship to learn about
love from a sociological and a
scientific perspective because i was
like oh my god like right right this is
why yeah i i totally get that but um
sometimes i find myself i'll speak for
myself that when i was dating a really
toxic
i'll say people
multiple people
they were often the ones that took me
the longest to get over yes and it was
the hardest
year year and a half and then the ones
that treat you really good it's like
we're almost able just to sort of move
on start dating again in two months did
you find that with your toxic
relationships or
because you educated yourself and you
became self-aware coming out of them
that you were able to sort of stop that
obsessive pattern of you know why won't
he love me why didn't he accept me et
cetera et cetera yeah well the toxic
ones i think again like they play on
your psyche so they're going to have a
longer hold on you and they probably
didn't end because you had naturally
decided that it was you know it was over
yeah it was because you had to rip
yourself free of it right so the other
ones that are like more peaceful or you
know better quote unquote people you
probably just got to a place over time
of like yeah i just fundamentally don't
think that we're good together whereas
in these relationships you're like i
know you're not good for me but i'm also
like heavily addicted to you and then
there's also like the sunk cost policy
or the casino effect that happens where
you've invested so much but so much time
into somebody that you're like i just
wasted so much time but you don't want
to realize that yes that you wasted all
your energy on someone that wasn't
reciprocating any of that love back yeah
then the way that you should deserve it
and you could be like on the other side
of this is there a better version of you
right and that's what i've been waiting
for this whole time and if i leave now
what if the next person who comes gets
that version right right so i think
there's just so much more at play
psychologically it's really fascinating
to me because i have somebody in my life
um who works with me and so i often hear
about people's love lives yeah right and
he is such a
classic textbook [ __ ] boy right um and
every time he listens to one of my
podcast episodes he's like i'm a gas
lighter he's like i do that
um and he's like becoming privy to these
words but like kind of serendipitously
learned without knowing what the
language is right like what are the
techniques that allow me to continue my
bad behavior right in order to get the
best out of people
um and people you have to kind of
acknowledge that too that like yeah some
people genuinely are literally [ __ ]
with you on purpose right yes yeah and i
also think i know this will never happen
but if you are a [ __ ] boy or you are a
gaslighter or even a [ __ ] girl right
it's better just to be up front and you
know what you're doing and you know the
games you're playing and you know that
you're toying people along but to act
like someone else
just to get you or or satisfy you or
sort of win a game in your head and then
do something completely different i mean
that's when i think it's the hardest for
people to because you're like who is
this person maybe i can try to fix them
yes not everyone is fixable
yes and i can say from like i've had
this conversation with that person
multiple times like just be open and
upfront yeah but for them
that person believes that there's a
chance of a relationship they believe in
exclusivity so they invest in gifts for
that person right they invest in more
they invest in sexual exclusivity for
them which they prize that you know so i
think that as much as it's like just be
honest that person is like yeah but if
i'm honest i might lose because right
now i'm getting everything that i want
right except for
people enjoying the experience of being
with me which i value very much right
right like it's you're creating a
dynamic where yes people are giving you
time attention money sex whatever but
they're like very uncomfortable within
it and you probably argue a lot but you
don't really prioritize that much as
much as you prioritize the things that
you're getting so the unfortunate thing
i had to kind of come to is like we kind
of want to believe that everybody's good
i mean this is a bad word no it's so
true you want to believe the best and
the worst of people you don't want to
believe that someone could be as bad as
they can be yes and it's hard to believe
especially when you are yourself someone
that isn't a manipulative person and all
you really want at the end of the day is
love that someone can truly do that and
intentionally do that to you it's like
when you've been conned yeah yeah and
you're like no one would really set up a
false business to trick old people out
of their hard-earned passion yes they
[ __ ] do or even like people stealing
out of your bag like no one's actually
gonna pickpocket me and like and take my
wallet and my credit cause i would never
want that to happen to somebody else so
why would i do that but like that person
that is it so i think that's a kind of a
part of the breaking free of the cycle
too of acknowledging that like yeah
there are genuinely people out there who
are aware that they're being harmful but
they prioritize the benefits they get
from that harm over that yeah and that's
just what it is do you think also
including sex and all of that because
love and then sex also that does release
endorphins and things like that and it
is it a fact that women bond or mate to
people that they do have sex with more
than men do yeah oxytocin which is like
the cuddle hormone the bonding hormone
um it is actually released in orgasm but
the highest dose of it is actually
released in after sex cuddling really
that's when the pair bond happens oh i
didn't know that so that can be helpful
too if you're trying to engage in like a
consensual
sexual strictly only sexual relationship
right is to really put in firm
boundaries i had that with my husband
when we were just [ __ ] buddies we never
ever ever did sleepovers oh really so no
sleepovers and you're willing to not and
because you wanted to make it clear that
this is just what it is we're not trying
to
produce feelings for each other i also
didn't want my body to outsmart me we're
like
that's true yeah well now i'm a slave to
feelings that i didn't consciously want
for myself right
right it's like with food right yeah
some people can have candies and treats
in the house and some people like i
can't even buy it because if it's there
i'll eat it yeah you have to learn how
to outsmart yourself just knowing your
tendencies right going on with ice cream
[Laughter]
literally last night you're like i can't
even i can't know i actually have
absolutely zero self-control i'm like
one of those people like if i'd have in
the house i will eat the whole bag i'm
like if there's a plate of there's
nothing wrong with indulging well there
is i consider myself to be like a love
addict like obviously i love love
oh my god if i don't put protections in
place for myself and i'm also a little
bit of an egomaniac um i went through a
period of time where like every dude
that i dated was like you're my soul
mate and that felt really good for me
even if i didn't feel the way towards
them right i'm like affirm me as being
great but then i'm like if i meet
somebody who knows how to play with that
okay
i can really get [ __ ] i need help with
this because i
will say yes to any person that will ask
me out i will
convince myself that i like this person
more than i actually do just because
maybe i'm filling the void in my life
that i'm lacking with a relationship
with this person but i know it's not
right
what ways because you just said that you
had to put up protection for yourself so
in what ways in your life did you
protect yourself that i can apply to
mine you got to just find other healthy
outfits like i love flirting you know i
like flirting because i like feeling
like sexy i love flirting i'm in a
relationship now so i can't do it at all
but it's just it was hardly in the
beginning because that was something
that i just used as a way to kind of get
attention or just like
enjoy life like that was my that was
just fun for me it was something that i
was just trying to get flirting is one
well you could find it or you could find
other ways because you could flirt with
complete strangers right you could flirt
with people who you know are of the
gender that you're not necessarily
attracted to totally so you're still
getting that kind of sexual exchange
right now you might
have a fake
username where you just chat with people
online like you find ways that you are
healthy outlets for you or you post
their straps on instagram and your
partner's okay with that and you get
flirty comments and like that satisfies
that part of yourself right without
creating those direct relationships
totally oh yeah i didn't even think
about that like there's different
outlets even sexually just to do it that
you can get satisfaction from them yeah
and i think that for me like i had to
make that switch i remember when i like
became really aware in my 30s dating
became amazing because i was just really
aware of myself and aware of like i
think it's better as you get older
not as it's not about age it's about
time well it's time like somebody who's
three years old in cambodia knows more
about cambodia than me so it's not about
age it's about how much time have you
invested in understanding stuff totally
yeah so i can meet a 17 year old who's
like nah my parents were on it i've been
reading psychological psychological
books i've been going to sex ed class
and yeah that person might have figured
[ __ ] out more than i have because
they've been investing more time i mean
i've been
more years than 17 uh 18 i said right
yeah they have to be 18 in order for us
to have that debate but nonetheless that
to be said i don't think it's about age
i think it's about investment of time
and i think at 30 i started my education
at 18 um and then i didn't actually
start learning about relationships until
27. i was only focused on sex for the
first bit and then i was like well what
about intimacy yeah so
that 30 i was like oh i know my [ __ ]
right i remember i went out on this date
with this dude and he was so hot and he
like washed my car for me what we had
this really great what did you do to get
him to do that just be myself you know
it's like really really positive to be
around i just get really happy when my
wheels are shiny exactly and he was he
took me to this rooftop and we were like
looking out together i'm having a great
time and then all of a sudden he got
like super sexual with me and it just
became like
very clear that his agenda the entire
time was left to do that yeah and i was
like uh and i was really turned on but
i'm like i have to leave and delete this
person's information because i know
one what kind of relationship is going
to lead to i know that my ego might be
like but i'll prove to you that i'm so
much more yeah and that i'm special for
watching my car just because i'm special
right and then i was like why why when i
can just delete it right that's that's a
really good point because i think um
a lot of people and i know myself for
sure it's like you want to again
perceive the best in people so
in my brain i'd be like but he did this
nice thing for him so i should like
you know let him continue with me but
if you cut off the cycle early you're
gonna avoid a lot of damage and red
flags later on and i always say that
like the red flags that you ignore in
the beginning of the relationship are
often the same ones
that you
you know you see that you break up with
it for that's just the same reason since
you've had your podcast and now people
are probably they feel like they can
like have more accessibility to like to
ask you questions what is the most
common question about sex that you've
received even if it's super simple that
people always frequently are curious
about yeah i guess because i guess
because i don't really get those comment
anymore of like specific things i mean
more or less
it's some version of like why won't this
person love me or why doesn't this work
like we tried x y and z we've done this
configuration this person won't come in
or i can't orgasm this relationship so
it's people who've like done some form
of troubleshooting on their own right
and they're getting to a place where
they're stuck because it's like beyond
what they can google or something simple
so i think like i get asked this
question all the time i should just come
up with some answer like what's the most
common question well it's probably just
back to the basics honestly it's
probably things that people it's not
anything probably really complex other
than like i don't feel pleasure with my
partner anymore or i don't know how to
keep it interesting and it is like even
the kissing thing is like people
probably want to know kissing tips that
just that improve their vocabulary or
like their what their knowledge is on it
and it's really interesting that at the
end of the day i think a lot of people
just have the same
curiosities yes but instead of it being
like how do i kiss better it'll be like
myself and my partner had our first kid
and as a result they stopped kissing me
because i now kiss the baby and that
feels weird to them so we're trying to
reignite our kissing style and then not
that person i'm not making something
yeah but like it's gonna be a question
that's like that versus like how do i
kiss better it won't be like how do i
have better annual we'll be like how do
i learn my partner's love language it's
gonna be like all these
multi-dimensional things which is should
just send the love language test to our
partner
yeah
tell us what you think it's actually
really fun and i feel like a lot of
people actually end up enjoying it once
they take and they're like oh the more
you know you know i feel like it's once
you open that door of potentially like
them learning about themselves more
because christina i've always been those
people that we love to
tell people to take these tests or just
very vocal about like yeah this is where
we are these are our zodiac signs this
is what we like
we don't get that we just send yeah we
did that group test that um she had on
netflix with the whole like what's your
sex preference and things like that if
it's like sensual or if it's kinky or if
it's sad um it's just so interesting
that people just they they do want to
know it's like unless you just it's just
opening that door and showing them that
it's really not that scary or it's
really easy and where you benefit or you
benefit and you realize like wait oh my
partner is more
physical touch and i'm more words of
affirmation so he knows that you have to
tell me that i look great today or like
i need that like or i love you or
anything or he needs more like i'll kiss
him or i'll hug him and it's just you
realize that it just becomes a lot more
simpler and fluid and easy once you
actually know that about yourself okay
yeah communicate i think that's just
what it is it's like communicating and
really asking the questions that are the
right ones that's the big part too
because i buck up against that bit of
advice of like a healthy relationship is
about communication which is similar to
being like good art it's about paint
true [ __ ] what paint yeah what canvas
how like yeah you know it to the point
of that like a lot of people aren't
really taught like what are the inner
workings of my intimate self like how do
i identify why i don't feel good with
someone because i might be able to
identify that like i don't feel
comfortable but the ability to say oh
it's because they misgendered me oh it's
because they don't speak my love
language oh it's because we have very
different conflict resolution styles
like that's where you can actually be
more action solution based so
it's interesting to me i think this
space is the one area where we're like
not you don't have to know when you can
figure it out that wouldn't apply to
anything else yeah right like if you
want to be good at any other topic in
this world you have to understand it and
know the various different like facets
and dynamics to it even the ones that
don't apply to you
because again you're going to be with
someone else who yeah maybe you don't
care about feet but you end up with a
foot fetish partner i was actually about
to ask that question if let's just say
you're interested in something or vice
versa they're interested in something
that you truly can't provide or maybe
it's something that is scary to you and
you really don't have an open mind to do
it because that's just not something
you're interested in what do you do when
you hit that wall like they're into feet
and you're not into feet yeah for
example a lot of people who have a
particular kink like have been
developing that and gain the confidence
for years and sometimes they spring it
on people in the moment and expect that
person to meet them where they are but
they've had like years and years or lots
of education lots of videos so i would
say first and foremost like you have to
be a bit more patient with people right
um and provide tools and resources for
their own time and their own studying
they might be surprised to find they can
come around or find different entry
points maybe like feet it's not the
right entry point because there's a
stigma there maybe instead it's like we
do leg massages or like i do hand stuff
with you so yeah not being so goal
oriented with our partners of like this
is what i want this is what i need can
you do it yeah yeah we're not like being
graceful of like it took me a long time
to get to a place where i can even ask
for that and know what that thing is
that's one but two you can get to
certain points with people where it's
like
i gave it the benefit of the doubt right
i watched the video i tried the thing
and it was i tried the hand massage the
whole time i was weirded out it's just
not my thing and now we come to a place
of like is this an area we can
compromise on or is this a fundamental
incompatibility that means that we
restructure our relationship totally
because that means if me how how is like
how is this going to affect our
relationship in the long run in terms of
like because sex might be really
important in the relationship and if
that's just not something that's
clicking then that is something you have
to consider for a long time is this
going to be a problem four years from
now a year months from now yeah because
like is that then a reason to move on or
is that and find someone that is
compatible with that you know i think
that's a hard question it's like
i don't necessarily think that not being
compatible on one certain sexual
preference or kink is a complete deal
breaker as long as both parties are
emotionally intelligent enough to you
know correctly verbalize what they're
willing to do or compromise on or right
you know i think as long as there's
understanding from both people i don't
think it's a deal-breaker well we've
identified it's not for you but for
somebody else exactly right that's what
i'm saying i always say that with like
you know like finances and people are so
judgmental about women who are
financially focused where it's like
they're probably things that you
prioritize heavily in a relationship
that matter a lot to you yeah that
wouldn't matter to that person right so
then it's like yeah there are some
people who they have to draw that line
and say either one we're gonna open the
relationship up so i can find outlets
for this because it's an important part
of how i want to experience this world
yeah we're not going to continue on
experiencing the world together and i'm
comfortable with that
well
mike dropped to that chan we could sit
here and talk to you yeah literally for
hours i mean i have like 100 more
questions but like we really got to wrap
it up i want everyone if you want to
continue to hear this conversation
you've got to check out her podcast
lovers and friends it's fantastic i
literally listened to five episodes
yesterday yeah
i really liked the ones um
it was about like dating in your 20s
like why it's the worst
i feel that i really do um tell everyone
where they can find
your podcast to streaming all of your
social media platforms yes well i
believe that people are like going to
remember one thing so i'll stick with
that one ask because that's the most
important thing i'm doing right now is
my podcast like it's longer form
discussions it's more in the vein of the
way that i want to do sex ed i think
everywhere else you have to make
compromises yeah because you're on
someone else's platform or because it's
30 seconds for a real or whatever so
this is a place where i'm like no this
is exactly the way that i want this
conversation to go right so my podcast
lovers and friends which is available
wherever they're listening to this
podcast yes everywhere everywhere oh my
gosh thank you so much for coming on
i found a new friend um thank you guys
for joining and we'll see you next
tuesday bye
[Music]
you